[Musique]
camilla et christophe était enfin comblé
ou presque après plusieurs tentatives de
fécondation in vitro échoué le couple
allait pouvoir entendre battre le coeur
de leur enfant à naître
au lieu de ça on me dit que mon bébé
allait mourir naoto kan a vendu pour 2
revers et qu'il n'y avait rien à faire
ce monstre c'était en avril de l'an
passé le début d'un long cauchemar la
méthode choc vous crois pas trop
ça a été un choc pour moi j'en ai perdu
souffle j'avais chaud
le médecin m'a dit que ce n'était pas de
la loi introduite par le gouvernement
actuel ils auraient été rompues ma
grossesse sur le champ
mais que j'allais devoir attendre que le
coeur du bébé s'arrête plus complet ce
matin mais pour ces médecins hors de
question d'avorter cette grossesse
pourtant condamné sony annonce lambda
naquit un os gueule tous les matins
j'avais une échographie des tests
sanguins pour vérifier si le bébé était
encore en
jeu ne pouvait qu'attendre allongé dans
mon lit
c'était terrible parce que je savais que
je perdais du liquide amniotique
je savais que mon bébé était en
souffrance qui l'étouffé et je ne
pouvais pas l'aider
[Musique]
lui elle et son mari l'ont appelé hubert
si camilla a été forcé de le porter
jusqu'à ce qu'il n'y ait plus aucun
signe de vie c'est qu'il y a un an une
décision de la cour constitutionnelle de
la pologne a pris effet cette dernière a
jugé anticonstitutionnelle
le fait d'avorter en cas de
malformations graves et irréversibles du
foetus ou de maladies incurables qui
menacent la vie du foetus
c'était jusque alors l'un des rares
motifs légaux pour recourir à
l'avortement en pologne ils
représentaient d'ailleurs plus de 90%
des quelques 1000 avortements légaux
pratiquées chaque année dans le pays
selon amnistie internationale
la très pieuse et conservatrice pologne
est descendu dans la rue en masse pour
dénoncer cette décision de la cour
si camilla a vécu un drame psychologique
inqualifiable elle soutient que le refus
de ces médecins d'avorter a mis sa
propre vie en danger
j'avais pas parce que je ne savais pas
ce qui allait se passer simon et als
aggravé développé une infection
j'avais pas de faire une hémorragie en
pleine nuit et que je ne pourrais pas
demander de l'aide
[Musique]
c'est ce qui est arrivé à isabela 30 ans
en septembre dernier enceinte de cinq
mois la jeune mère de famille est morte
alors qu'elle ne pouvait avorter les
circonstances de son décès ont été
rendus public par sa famille en novembre
isabella avait échangé avec sa mère par
message texte peu avant sa mort lui
disant tout sapeur ma fièvre monte
écrivait-elle c'est l'horreur je suis en
danger
lorsque ces métiers ont tenté une
césarienne il était déjà trop tard vous
avez là est décédé d'un choc septique
une erreur médicale s'est défendu
l'hôpital une explication qui n'a pas
convaincu une grande partie des polonais
qui ont renouvelé les manifestations en
masse pour demander le droit à
l'avortement
depuis l'arrêté de la cour il ya un an
l'avortement en pologne est légal
seulement en cas de viol et de danger
pour la santé de la mère ceux qui
pratiqueraient des interruptions de
grossesse en cas de malformation du
foetus risque jusqu'à trois ans de
prison hmm hmm de gens et c'est là tout
le problème dit cette féministe ce sont
les médecins qui ont peur d'interrompre
la grossesse qui est épars 2 qui a foutu
mais quand même il faut à maintenir la
vie du foetus même au coût de la vie de
famille et c'est ça qui a changé c'est
ça qui est vraiment un profond demande
bovins sont
les réseaux parallèles d'entr'aide entre
femmes étaient déjà en plein essor
aujourd'hui ils se disent débordés dans
les bureaux de celles qui se sont
baptisés équipe de rêve de l'avortement
le téléphone sonne sans arrêt
[Musique]
à l'autre bout du fil des femmes qui
souhaitent interrompre leur grossesse
elles sont alors dirigés vers les
ressources qui s'offrent à elle à
l'étranger et fait à deux first touch of
quick ce nouveau bilan porte à des
acheteurs
easyjet
pyromane a drug and is about to get him
to your ont fait pratiquement
toute manette you can't take you it's a
fucking au procès et ses possibilités
pour celles qui n'auraient pas les
moyens ces organisations offrent aussi
le financement du voyage en allemagne et
aux pays bas le plus souvent et le coût
de l'intervention depuis octobre 2000 20
34 mille femmes polonaises ont ainsi pu
avorter dans 80% des cas elles ont eu
recours à la pilule abortive est un peu
plus de 1000 d'entre elles ont dû faire
le voyage à l'étranger de mons tim
burton signe fort et tu regardes la
prochaine at the time and tide
water à dubaï
mais au delà de huy a prioris date aux
abords chaise know about the people the
bold and shoulders of de cette forêt
network dans we are in fact duendes
benida merrah
et chacun d'entre nous à
comprends que ça peut être moi
que si
moi je n'aurai pas de
de l'assistance j'aurais part de l'aide
je peux mourir justement mourir pour la
grossesse donc c'est ça c'est assez
inquiétant c'est
effrayant même
parce que nous sommes vraiment à rezé
non la polonaise the woodlands c'est
bien de la terreur que camilla a
ressenti une terreur imposée par l'état
croit-elle et elle souhaite que les
femmes polonaises en soit libéré
longtemps elle a hésité à raconter son
histoire de peur d'être stigmatisés
bouscarrat monsieur
x j'essaie de rester braves et de garder
la tête haute et de raconter claudine si
ce n'était de l'appui le ma famille est
au pouvoir je ne pourrais pas parler de
ce que j'ai vécu
ils m'ont encouragé à le faire pour que
les gens comprennent ce qu'est ce qui
s'passe vos glandes
camilla ignore si elle pourra un jour
enterré sa souffrance qui peut et ne
veut certainement plus la terre